It's been 20 years since The Matrix changed
genre cinema forever.
And now, Lana Wachowski, Keanu Reeves, and
Carrie-Anne Moss are returning for a fourth
film.
So we’re taking a look at some of the biggest
questions we want answered in The Matrix 4.
Now that we know Keanu Reeves is returning
for more of The Matrix, the big question is
how his character, Neo, comes back after his
apparent death in The Matrix Revolutions.
The Oracle suggests we might see him again
at the end of the last film...
"Will we ever see him again?"
"I suspect so.
Someday."
...but his body is carried away by the Machines
after he defeats Agent Smith and reboots the
Matrix.
There are a number of ways the film could
explain Neo's return, the most obvious of
which is by telling us he didn't really die
after all, and that the Machines ultimately
nursed him back to health.
Then there's the explanation that because
of his status as "the One," Neo was always
at least partially a software creation, the
product of programming mixing with biology.
Perhaps the software in him survived and reincarnated
into the new Matrix.
Whatever the case, we can't wait to see how
we get him back.
"Yeah, I'm thinkin' I'm back!"
Neo is the One, so there are all kinds of
possibilities through which that character
could return from the dead.
But how exactly will Carrie-Anne Moss return
as Trinity?
Her character is quite clearly dead after
being impaled on machinery at the end of The
Matrix Revolutions.
She's an amazing warrior, but she's not The
One.
Thankfully, the sci-fi realm of this franchise
offers plenty of possibilities for her return
as well.
Humans aren't born so much as they're grown,
which leaves the door open for genetic engineering,
cloning, and all manner of other things.
Perhaps Trinity was replicated.
There's also the possibility that Trinity
now only exists as software, a program within
the Matrix conceived to replace her physical
self, made from preserved data about her personality
and appearance.
However it happens, her return could ultimately
be even more fascinating than Neo's.
While Neo and Trinity journey to the Machine
City to put an end to the war in The Matrix
Revolutions, Morpheus stays behind to help
with the final battle at Zion, arriving at
the last minute so Link could activate an
EMP that effectively pauses the battle so
the humans can prepare for their last stand.
When Neo reaches a truce with the Machines,
Morpheus is among the survivors of Zion, one
of the last surviving leaders of the free
human race.
Laurence Fishburne, who played Morpheus in
the original Matrix trilogy, was notably absent
from the list of names attached to the new
film.
That doesn't necessarily mean he won't be
in the movie, but in the event Fishburne's
not around, then what happened to Morpheus?
Does the story just not concern him?
Will he be played by a different actor?
He's too big of a presence in the franchise
for the film to ignore, so we can't wait to
see how The Matrix 4 explains what happened
to everybody's favorite freedom fighter.
The Matrix Reloaded and The Matrix Revolutions
established that the Matrix is full of rogue
programs.
Some of these are from much older versions
of the Matrix, and they have their own agendas,
plans, and seemingly supernatural abilities.
The Oracle tells Neo that these are the source
of humanity's stories about vampires, werewolves,
and other creatures, as the programs basically
do as they please after refusing deletion.
When the Matrix rebooted at the end of Revolutions,
we saw that both the Oracle and the Architect
were still present, but what about the rogue
programs?
Is the Merovingian still scheming within the
next version of the simulation?
Is the Trainman?
What other rogue programs might have resisted
deletion the last time around and are operating
now?
It'll be very interesting indeed to see the
state of rogue programs in the new version
of this world.
In The Matrix Reloaded, Neo meets a character
called Seraph, a program serving and protecting
the Oracle.
The guy acts as an authenticator for visitors
by fighting them before they can see her.
It's eventually made clear that Seraph is
unusual, even by the standards of other programs
with strange abilities.
When Neo looks at him through the Matrix's
code, he sees a golden, burning light while
everything else around Seraph is green.
At one point, one of the Merovingian's thugs
refers to him as "wingless."
In the multiplayer game The Matrix Online,
it's revealed that Seraph once acted as an
agent in the first version of the Matrix,
the "paradise" version, making him something
akin to an angel.
Seraph's "angel" status makes him apparently
second only to Neo in terms of fighting ability,
and his status as a product of the first Matrix
makes him one of the oldest programs in existence.
So will he show up in The Matrix 4?
He's a fascinating character, and it would
be great to see the next film return to him
as a key part of the mythos.
At the end of Revolutions, Neo manages to
negotiate a peace between the Machines and
the humans.
Human civilization would be allowed to continue
in some form, and humans would have a chance
to leave the Matrix upfront.
So what does human civilization look like
now?
it'll be interesting to see what's changed.
Is Zion still the only human city?
Have humans found a way to survive on the
surface with the Machines' heavy pollution?
Are there more people?
The biggest question is whether the peace
lasted, and if so, for how long?
"Just how long do you think this peace is
going to last?"
"As long as it can."
The Architect took a cynical view of things,
so it's quite possible that he began at that
very moment to explore new ways to subjugate
and undermine humanity's future as supposedly
free.
And since so much of the thematic weight of
The Matrix is already tied up in themes of
determinism versus free will, it's easy to
see how that cycle would begin again.
It's also possible that humans have used their
newfound ability to leave the Matrix and begin
a kind of cold war with the Machines, with
the hope of wiping them out entirely.
If you're the type of fan who likes to pick
apart the world established in The Matrix,
you may have arrived at a lingering question:
Why wouldn't the Machines have adopted alternative
means of energy rather than just farming humans?
After the peace established in The Matrix
Revolutions, it's a question that has to come
up again.
With humans now granted the freedom to choose
to leave the Matrix or not as the result of
Neo's sacrifice, how have the Machines adapted
to their new co-existence?
Have they adopted alternative means of energy?
If humanity changed, then the Machines likely
had to do some kind of adjusting as well,
and that will be quite an interesting idea
for The Matrix 4 to explore.
Where Neo had to be dragged out of the Matrix
after some convincing by Morpheus, humans
will now be given an upfront decision.
They can leave the simulated universe they
know for a free and real life in a harsher
world, or they can stay in the Matrix with
all its simulated modern comfort.
"Ohhhh.
Ignorance is bliss."
As the original trilogy made clear, there
were some who will choose to forget about
the real world and simply carry on living
in the Matrix, with modern conveniences, while
others will choose reality.
Now that everyone gets to make that choice,
the big question is what will that choice
look like?
How do the Machines present their argument?
Do both sides try to convince souls in the
Matrix to stay or go?
If you're born outside the Matrix, can you
try it and see if you'd like to stay?
The film reportedly starts production in early
2020, so maybe it won't be too long before
we find out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about upcoming
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.